it was a pleasure to be a part of your
campaign and I think you're doing a
great job trying to make people more
aware of this gender pay gap but tell me
why is it so why is it so prevalent
among Millennials so one of the
challenges that we're finding is that
despite all the progress that has been
made there's still a very low level of
awareness that the gender pay gap is
still a challenge for this generation
that's entering the workforce today so
in the survey results that we began to
discuss earlier we found that the
majority of our millennial users who
were female did not think that the wage
gap applied to them and when we showed
them data that said okay wait a minute
but already one year out of college
statistically speaking you're already
going to be making seven to eight cents
less than your male counterpart this
starts early and then this magnifies
over time the perception changed and
then it became a question of not knowing
how to ask
we found that then 66 percent of our
members weren't sure exactly how can I
ask what is the right way to do this am
I going to lose the offer that's in
front of me if I do this incorrectly and
harken back to some of the fears that
you were mentioning in your office hour
segment yeah well exactly okay so so
what about this Ellen Powell of the
famous case now against kleiner perkins
says I'm at reddit here I'm the interim
CEO I'm gonna just completely cancel and
eliminate all salary negotiations what
about that solution so one of the things
that's really interesting is that in
Washington DC this the wage gap is the
smallest in any in any city in the
United States and part of that is
because all of the federal jobs that
these millennial women and millennial
men are getting in DC have more
transparent salary tables that are that
anybody can reference and it makes the
point of departure a lot more clear and
transparent from the get-go so it's
there's there's something interesting
around that transparency what I don't
want to get lost is the need to
negotiate from the beginning because if
you've already begun your career then
it's important for you to understand if
you're already earning the average that
you deserve for for your career
tract and for your area okay so there
are going to be several people on the
other side Caroline who don't believe
that this gender pay gap exists because
there's widespread discrimination and it
was interesting because I got an email
in my box this morning from a group
called the Independent Women's Forum I
don't know much about them but I'm gonna
just give you a quote from their
statement because they are very
vehemently against equal pay day
they say they call it a fictitious
holiday they say quote the statistical
difference between women and men's
average earnings isn't driven by
widespread sexism
but largely from different choices men
and women make throughout our lives so
what do you say to that I think we have
to be very careful what conclusions we
draw from data so the research that we
have is the best available around the
difference between men and women in the
course of their careers and what we've
found as a factor that we can affect
today with this new generation entering
the workforce through the types of
resources and connections that we offer
on Laveau is enabling people to advocate
for themselves to negotiate to
understand how much they should be
earning there is absolutely a piece of
this that that is institutional but what
we're really focused on is the
individual and enabling the individual
to be successful to the extent that that
person can affect their own success and
really come into a negotiation with the
best foot forward